- [Instructor] What I
want to do in this video
is review a little bit
of what we've learned
about monopolies and, in the process,
get a better understanding for
some of the graphical representations,
which we have talked about in the past,
but I wanna put it all
together in this video here.
So let's say that the
industry that we are in,
the demand curve looks
something like that.
That is demand and I'm going to assume
that it is a linear demand curve.
This axis right here is dollars per unit.
In the context of demand, that's price,
and this is quantity over here.
This little graph here,
we still have quantity
in the horizontal axis,
but the vertical axis isn't
just dollars per unit,
it's absolute level of dollars.
Over here we can actually plot
total revenue as a function
of quantity, total revenue.
Remember, we're assuming
we're the only producer here.
We have a monopoly,
we have a monopoly in this market.
So if we pick a quantity,
if we don't produce anything,
we're not going to generate any revenue,
so our total revenue will be zero.
If we produce a bunch, but we
don't charge anything for it,
and that's this point right over here,
our total revenue will also be zero.
We've done this in other videos,
but then as we increase
quantity from this point,
our total revenue will keep
going up and up and up.
There'll be some maximum point
and then it'll start going down again,
so our total revenue would
look something like this.
Total revenue would look something
like that, total revenue.
And from the total
revenue, we can think about
what the marginal revenue would look like.
Remember, the marginal revenue just says
if I increase my quantity by a little bit,
how much am I increasing my total revenue?
So that's essentially the slope,
the slope of the total revenue
curve at any given point,
or you can think of it as the
slope of the tangent line.
We've seen before, when you start here,
you have a very high, positive slope
and we've seen in other videos
it actually ends up being
the exact same value
as where the demand curve
intersects the vertical axis
right over there,
but then it keeps going lower,
the slope becomes a little less
deep, less deep, less deep.
It's still positive, less deep, less deep,
and then it becomes zero right over there
and then it starts going negative.
It becomes zero right at that quantity.
The slope of this keeps
going down and down and down,
it's positive, then it becomes zero,
and then it actually becomes
negative and you see that here.
Now it starts downward
sloping even more steep,
even more steep, and even more steep.
That's the revenue side of things.
Let me label this, this is
our marginal revenue curve,
slope of the total revenue.
If we're gonna maximize profit,
we need to think about
what our costs look like,
so let me draw our total cost curve.
And I will do it in magenta.
Let's say our total costs
look something like this.
Total cost looks something like that.
Out here, where we have very few units,
where we have zero units, all
of our costs are fixed costs.
And then as we produce
more and more units,
the variable costs start
piling on over there.
Even from this diagram, you can actually
start to visually see economic profit.
Economic profit, and when
we're talking costs and profit
in an economics class, like
this is kind of one, I guess,
remember, you should view it
in terms of economic profit
and when we're talking about total cost,
we're talking about opportunity cost.
So this is total opportunity cost,
both the implicit,
both the explicit,
the ones that you're actually
paying money for explicitly
and the implicit opportunity costs.
Total opportunity costs,
that's total opportunity cost
and the difference between
your total revenue,
so for a given quantity,
the difference between
your total revenue and your
total opportunity cost,
that gives you your economic profit.
For this quantity right over here,
your economic profit would be represented
by the height of this little
bar between these two curves.
But what we see what's going on is,
as we increase the quantity over here,
these curves are getting
further and further apart.
That's because the green
curve, the total revenue,
it's slope is larger
than this purple curve,
which is total opportunity cost,
or you could say it total cost.
So we could go even further along,
just the distance between the two curves
gets bigger, bigger,
looks like it maxes out
right around here someplace
and then the two things start getting
closer and closer together.
This purple curve's slope is now larger
than the orange curve's slope,
so then they start getting
closer and closer together.
If you were to just look at this graph,
whatever the maximum distance
between these two things are,
it looks like it's about
there, right over here,
that would be your
maximum economic profit.
But we know we can also visualize it
on this curve over here.
And we can do that by
plotting our marginal cost.
And remember, marginal costs,
this is marginal revenue,
is the slope of your total revenue curve.
Marginal cost is the slope,
the instantaneous slope at any point
of your total cost curve.
So I will do that,
let's do that in yellow.
Right over here, you have a zero slope,
or pretty close to zero,
at least the way I drew it over there.
So your marginal cost is going to be
pretty close to zero right over there.
And then we see this slope
keeps increasing and increasing
and increasing and so our
marginal cost will keep
increasing, increasing, and increasing,
so it will look something like that.
That is our marginal cost curve.
If we pick a quantity and if we find
that the marginal cost over here,
I don't know, let's say that
it's five dollars per unit,
that literally means that the slope,
that that same quantity, the
slope of our total cost curve,
that the slope over there
would have to be five.
That's what that is telling us.
This is plotting the slope of
this curve right over here.
And if we want to maximize profit,
we already talked about how
you would do it visually
on this curve, we can do it over here.
Well, right over here, as we produce,
if we start from producing
nothing to producing something,
for each incremental unit,
the incremental revenue we get on that
is much higher than the incremental cost.
So, hey, we should produce it
because we're gonna get profit there.
We could keep producing
because we're gonna get profit
on each of these incremental units,
so we'll keep doing it,
we'll keep doing it,
until the marginal revenue
is equal to the marginal cost.
At that point, it doesn't make sense
for us to produce anymore.
If we produce an extra
unit past that point,
on that unit our cost will
be higher than our revenue,
so what will eat into our economic profit.
So this right over here is
where we max the quantity,
which we maximize profit.
When we see it, we see
it right over there.
The way I drew it, luckily, it looks like
that is the maximum point
between those two curves as well,
and it makes sense.
Before this point, when marginal revenue
is higher than marginal cost,
that means that the slope
of the total revenue curve
is larger than the slope
of the total cost curve,
so they're getting
further and further apart.
After this point, and right at that point
their slopes are the same,
so the slopes are going to
be the same right over there,
and then after that point,
the slope of the marginal cost curve,
sorry, the marginal cost is high,
which tells us the slope of
the total cost curve is higher,
than the slope of the total revenue curve.
And so they're gonna get
closer and closer together
and this distance gets squinched apart.
That is where you maximize profit.
And if you wanted to
visualize the actual profit,
on this graph over here,
we cannot obviously visualize it here
as the distance between these two curves.
If you want to visualize it over here,
we would have to plot our
average total cost curve.
And essentially, what you're doing is
you're just taking this total cost curve
and you're not just taking
the slope at any point,
that's the marginal cost,
instead you're just dividing
it by the quantities.
So if you take this total cost curve,
you take this value and you divide it by
very, very, very low quantity,
you're going to get a very,
very, very, very large number.
You can imagine, as you're
spreading your fixed costs
amongst a very small quantity,
so you're gonna get a very large number.
Then, as you produce
more and more and more,
your average total costs go down,
but then your variable
costs start picking up
and your average total costs
might look something like that.
Average total costs.
And so, if you wanna know your profit
that you have maximized from
this graph right over here,
you say this is the quantity
that maximizes my profit,
marginal revenue is
equal to marginal costs,
the price that I can get in
the market for that quantity,
you go up to your demand
curve and it gives you,
this is the price that you
will get for that quantity
and so that is, on a per unit basis,
that is the revenue that you will get.
You can view price is equal to,
price is the same thing as revenue,
revenue per unit.
So on a per unit basis, this
is the revenue you're getting,
and on a per unit basis,
this is your average cost,
this is average total costs.
This is taking all your costs
and dividing it by units.
On an average, per unit basis,
this is going to be your economic profit.
On a per unit basis, and
if you wanted to find your
actual economic profit,
you would have to multiply it
by the total number of units.
So you would, essentially, have the area
of this rectangle right over here.
This is your per unit
average economic profit
and so your total economic profit
is going to be quantity
times profit per unit
and so this right over
here is economic profit,
or maybe I should call it
the total economic profit.
Let me write it out,
total
economic
profit.
And the area of that rectangle
should be the same thing as the height
of this right over here.
The only reason, and we can maintain
this is a sustainable scenario
because we have a monopoly.
No one else can enter.
If this was not a monopoly,
if there were no barriers to entry,
then other people say hey,
there's economic profit there,
that means that there's an incentive
for me to put those
same resources together
and try to compete
because I'm going to get
better returns than my opportunity costs
than my alternatives is a
good way to think about it.